can you believe it the number one seed
is
upset do you believe in miracles
[Music]
sponsored by indochino when we look back
on the unmitigated disaster that was the
kovid 19 pandemic
there aren't going to be a lot of bright
spots but perhaps one of the good things
to come out of it is the preponderance
of
ridiculous videos involving zoom court
hearings
i mean when you add lawyers judges
criminals and sometimes florida man
you're gonna get
some ridiculous results so as we start
to come out of this whole thing
let's rank them and the good people over
and above the law have done the hard
work and they have compiled
16 of the most ridiculous epic zoom
fails that have happened during the
pandemic if you care about legal
industry insider news you should
definitely be reading above the law.com
led by commentators like joe patrice and
until recently ellie missed all two of
my favorite legal commentators out there
so let's look at the sweet 16 of epic
lawyer zoom call
fails and see who comes out on top
so we start with the number one seed i'm
still not a cat
mr ponton i believe you have a filter
turned on
in the video settings
uh you might want to uh
we're trying to can you hear me judge
i can hear you i think it's a filter
it is and i don't know how to remove it
i've got my assistant here she's trying
to but
uh i'm prepared to go forward with it
that's i'm here live that's not i'm not
a cat i must have seen this video i
don't know a dozen times and it
still makes me laugh i'm still not a cat
as if
that actually needed to be explained to
the judge this is
obviously the number one seed it's gonna
be really tough for any other
zoom fail to top this one the cat filter
the sad eyes
the the pleading from the attorney it's
just
it's just uh zoom call perfection i'm
not a cat this is a really really tough
matchup for the 16 seed here
which is just a letter from a clearly
exasperated judge
in florida saying that look you need to
show up
for zoom hearings with some concern for
how you look the judge is trying to have
some sort of decorum here reminding
people not to wear
casual shirts and blouses that this is
not just a
normal phone conversation with their
friends and most importantly
you have to wear at least a shirt to a
zoom hearing
uh i mean look florida lawyers are going
to florida lawyer there's no getting
around that it's like syracuse running a
zone defense
and you know they're going to do it
every year easily the number one seed
i'm still not a cat defeating
underdog the western bar association of
florida
i'm prepared to go forward with it all
right that takes us to our next matchup
and if you thought that it wasn't
possible to get any dumber than
florida people appearing in florida
court
george you is so gorgeous i just have to
tell you
well jeffrey tubin said hold my beer
according to press reports at some point
tuban engages in an intimate act of
self-gratification seemingly unaware
that a zoom camera is on for his part
tubin calls the incident an embarrassing
and
stupid mistake yeah i think we all
remember what happened to jeffrey tubin
many of you probably have not seen the
video so here is the uncensored video of
jeffrey toobin on a video call
i'm obviously kidding i'm not going to
show you that
but uh yeah always a good reminder that
uh you shouldn't cast
stones if you aren't prepared to walk
the walk at least with
pants so jeffrey toobin falls from
grace he's up against the doctor who
appeared at a
traffic court while actually in surgery
so unless i'm mistaken i'm seeing a
defendant that's in the middle of an
operating room appearing to be actively
engaged in
providing services to a patient is that
correct mr green
yes sir yeah this is terrifying
i do not feel comfortable uh for the
welfare of a patient if you're in the
process of
operating that i would put on a trial
please please
don't appear in court don't whether it's
on
zoom or any other way if you're actively
operating on a person this is crazy i
covered this earlier in the year but my
god what craziness had to be going
through this guy's head
another surgeon right here who's doing
the surgery with me so i can stand here
and allow them to do the surgery also
look if you have to reschedule if
there's a medical emergency you can call
up the court clerk
and you can rearrange your hearing i i
don't think so i don't think that's
appropriate i think we're going to have
i'm going to come up with a different
date
this was a surprisingly tough match-up i
understand why jeffrey tubin was the
number two seed here
but i have to say that i think the 15
seed of doctor
appearing in court while actively
potentially harming
a patient who was undergoing cosmetic
surgery
just did it blows my mind in such a way
that i i think i'm going to give it to
the 15 seed jeffrey toobin is unseated
pun intended uh and we're gonna give it
to the doctor
operating on a patient just don't do
that that is mind-bogglingly crazy
so that takes us to perhaps the most
prestigious matchup of the tournament
we have the oral argument at the u.s
supreme court
in which someone flushes a toilet during
the oral argument
let's see what happened here marketing
some other product maybe they're going
to be saying hey call your congressman
and uh change these laws that apply to
the standards
that is very clearly a toilet being
flushed the subject matter of the fall
ranges from topics yeah i mean i've been
saying for years that the supreme court
is going down the toilet
[Music]
so the funniest thing about this whole
thing is that the supreme court
hates the loss of decorum and this must
have made john roberts head
explode because he really cares about
these sorts of things
famously you can't take a video camera
into the us supreme court so
the fact that they were finally allowing
live oral arguments
oh boy at least over zoom calls like
this it's just uh
yeah you can imagine that the justices
were not happy about this at
all so the supreme court toilet was up
against
just your garden variety naked lawyer
this time in california though not
actually
in florida for once yeah so a guy that
looks like uh
an 80s wrestler i think he actually does
have a mullet here that's
that's sort of interesting he just you
know appeared with no clothes on
whatsoever
and then received uh remonstrations from
the judge
this lawyer could really use a new suit
and tie
and shirt and underwear indochino
yeah i mean you know there's there's
some heart going on with this one
uh with just not bothering to put on
clothes for an oral argument
but i because of the prestige of the
supreme court i'm
handing it to the number three seed
easily uh supreme court
oral argument while the toilet is
flushing wins this round all right that
brings us to the final top seed of this
whole
tournament we knew it was bound to
happen that
with enough zoom hearings someone was
going to get it on
with the camera on and as it happened
apparently in peru uh that actually
happened that after the hearing was over
the cameras were still rolling
and the lawyer just just got it on
yeah well look i mean people have urges
right uh i guess the worst part is that
this was actually happening
what what appears to be the lawyer's
office so that's
just not good for pandemic purposes
either i mean you know socially distance
yikes but that's up against a real
underdog here just a tweet of
what is assumed to have happened uh
during a zoom hearing i had given an
attorney some instructions when he
snapped
sneaky i said um sir we can still hear
you
he clarified that his dog had just
pooped on the rug
yeah a lot of heart in this one but we
don't actually know that
they intended this to be directed
at the judge we presumed that it was but
perhaps it was
just a mix-up and it's one of those
things where you know the dog ate my
homework
or you know the dog pooped on the floor
this one no real contest you're gonna
have to give it to the lawyers that are
actually
flaunting all of the regulations and
ethical requirements for lawyers and
just
actually getting it on in their offices
uh
boy yeah easy win for the number four
seed
so that takes us to our next matchup
here we have
oh how do i put this um very aggressive
oral argumentation here there is
a female attorney at her desk but there
seems to be something going on
just beneath the desk that does not seem
to be
on the up and up
again these things are bound to happen
but man
you know save it for for after hours
that is the uh the workplace is not the
right place for this
and speaking of not the right time or
place we have the opponent
uh another zoom call where you they just
decided
not to wear any clothes whatsoever
they're shenanigans
so today's my gonzaga day that's how
it's done
let's make sure everybody has clothes uh
this one is a bit
more graphic in that they literally
stand up for apparently no apparent
reason
and what makes this particularly funny
here though is this is a civil procedure
class in law school uh where you would
think that they would know better and
also
why are people just running around all
day long without clothes on
just you know put some pants on
man you think law students would know
better
i'm gonna have to give this to the law
student that is incredibly embarrassing
people keep saying you know put your
clothes on and they're
people are audibly distressed at what's
going on
no your your video is on so i guess the
the second
upset of the tournament here that brings
us to the michigan division of the
tournament
here we have a man attends a zoom court
hearing
from his own victim's home i mean this
is this is some craziness
you are and i have reason to believe
that the defendant is in the same
apartment
as the complaining witness right now and
i'm
extremely scared for her safety and then
they realize that
both the alleged abuser and the alleged
victim are in the same location
i want you to walk out to the front of
the house show me the house number on
the house
there is some order that the restraining
order basically that says they can't be
anywhere near each other
yeah people don't want no contact
i asked if that be dropped i'm sorry i
lied to you yeah and then they argue
that
they don't want this order to be in
place and the police come
and arrest this guy for violating this
restraint order
take the cigarette out of your mouth the
hearing is
adjourned man that's crazy i mean this
happens in michigan
in exactly the same courtroom as the
judge
in the opponent where the guy is
attending a suspended license hearing
from actually being in a car the one i'm
struggling with
is the driving suspended i believe you
drove to wherever you are
in the vehicle you're in and you're dumb
enough to come on video with you sitting
in the driver's seat of a vehicle
what would you like me to know sir that
i'm not sending my own vehicle and i
didn't drive here that uh
i'm sitting in my boss's vehicle
currently because i'm in court
i wasn't trying to do corey in a
customer's house i mean you expect this
sort of behavior from
teams from from florida but from not
from michigan i mean
kudos to judge middleton here who seems
to handle this
with uh with confidence and and respect
but uh
this guy is seeing a whole bunch of crap
in his own courtroom both of these
things happened
with the same judge and the same
prosecutor incredible
i'm gonna have to give this to boy the
the victim
and abuser being in the same house
that's crazy i'm glad that there was a
good result with the police coming by
and and extricating the the guy from
this house but
that's uh boy that is unusual you don't
see that every day
or every tournament this is a
issue we didn't have when we were at
live court all right that brings us to
the food and pajamas division
uh the first up is the lawyer fails to
turn off his camera
while he's eating lunch now that doesn't
sound too bad but let's let's see what's
going on here
yeah so he's just he's going to town
on that lunch he is boy
yeah you know you'd think you would just
you know wait until the hearing is over
who knows if the judge is going to ask
you to actually say something
uh while you're chomping down on a
sandwich i think not best practices
you know if you're in front of the judge
you probably should not be scarfing down
on an enormous lunch
for this entire time put the sandwich
away
[Music]
all right versus a lawyer being
reprimanded for not wearing a tie
and more here we have
an ex-party communication so you're not
allowed to talk to the judge
or send emails to the judge alone if
you're going to do that you have to copy
your post and counsel on it and the
judge says the email states that i would
not consider an application from him
because he was quote
was not wearing a tie that is true as
the record reflects
what the record also reflects is that mr
weisbrot
appeared in court for trial via zoom on
tuesday in either a
printed t-shirt or pajamas it was
difficult to discern
yeah so so if you object
that the judge is reprimanding you for
not wearing a tie
and you are in fact wearing either a
pre-printed t-shirt or pajamas you
probably
don't have the better of the argument uh
and maybe you should not be complaining
to the judge that you're being
reprimanded for
going to court tiles i'm just gonna go
out on a limb there
i'm gonna give this to scarfing down
lunch that's hilarious and it's
my god it's still going
put the lunch away man jeez so
you know i guess that's the equivalent
of overtime in this tournament
all right so that brings us to the top
law school bracket here
uh we have on the one hand the comments
from a
professor a lot of my lower ones
are blacks happens almost every semester
yeah i think we've seen this comment
before that's
um that is a very unfortunate way of
phrasing that and that's really too bad
uh versus harvard law the federalist
society
president apparently brings a gun to
class and i can't imagine how bad that
would oh my god
why would you do that ah
boy i'm just gonna say that both of
these are completely disqualified
from participating in the law school
bracket now and
in the future so that's just a that's a
dq all around
[Music]
all right so now we just need to figure
out the elite eight uh so here we have
still not a cat that
handily beats the disqualified
georgetown and harvard bracket so they
advance
and then we have the afternoon delight
uh versus the civ
pro streaker i'm gonna give it to the
sid pro streaker just because they were
so
incredibly clueless ben get your stuff
together man
why are you attending sid pro completely
naked uh so
uh civ pro streaker advances uh then we
have
let's see code blue uh versus a man's
got to eat so this is the sandwich
versus the doctor in the er
tough call tough call but i'm gonna give
it to the underdog again
the uh the doctor in the operating room
yeah attending a call while you're in
surgery that's malpractice whereas
eating a lunch in front of the judge
that's just mal's sandwich
then we have the scotus toilet flush
versus catching an abuser
in the same home as the uh the alleged
victim here
ah i mean that's that's so sad i'm just
gonna have to give it again
to the supreme court toilet flush here
again
purely based on making john roberts the
chief justice's head
explode here he must have absolutely
hated that
i think the they get extra points for
the lack of decorum at the supreme court
so supreme court toilet flush advances
okay things are really starting to heat
up here we have
uh still a cat let's check in on the
floor
mr attorney are you still a cat i'm here
live that's not
i'm not a cat he is still a cat ladies
and gentlemen still
a cat versus civ pro ben ben can you
hear us
ben did you get yours together
no ben can't hear us so still not a cat
advances to the finals that brings us a
doctor who should not be having a zoom
hearing
in the operating room versus the supreme
court toilet flush
uh doctor have you stopped operating on
your your patient
i have another surgeon right here who's
doing the surgery with me so i can stand
here and allow them to do the surgery
also
ooh that's gonna cost him uh and the
supreme court is there still a working
toilet in the supreme court the subject
matter of the fall
ranges to the topic yes there is
still a toilet the cinderella story of
the supreme court toilet advances
to the finals so that takes us to the
finals we have still a cat who's let me
check in
are they still a cat yes they are still
a cat i've got my assistant here she's
trying to but
oh versus the supreme court toilet let's
check in ladies and gentlemen is there
still
a toilet at the supreme court
yes yes my god they've done it there is
still a toilet at the supreme court
they've done it the cinderella story
throughout this entire tournament
do you believe in miracles and toilets
at the supreme court the team that
made the chief justice's head explode
they have
done it my goodness march madness
is incredible every year the supreme
court oral argument toilet
wins for the first time in history just
incredible
and if we've learned anything from these
lawyers is that wearing a suit to court
or
any clothes at all is more important
than ever and all of my suits come from
indochino including this one that i'm
wearing right now it was custom made
just for me and by the way if you've
ever wondered which particular suits i'm
wearing
you can actually click on the link below
in the description and see the entire
legal eagle collection at indochino it
has all of my suits you can actually
get the exact same fabric and customize
it for yourself
because if you can't tell i'm thrilled
that indochino is back they are
my favorite and whether you are
returning to work and need a new suit
that fits
after the covid 19 pounds or if you're
going through with that wedding that you
postponed and
all of the groomsmen need matching
tailored suits indochino is 100
the way to go and mazeltov by the way
because the secret to a great suit is
all about the fit and
i'm a reasonably athletic guy but i can
never buy suits off the rack because
they just simply never fit right
if the shoulders fit the waist is too
small it either doesn't fit or it costs
a ton
to have a tailor fix it but with
indochino you can send in your
measurements online or you can go to one
of their hundreds of stores
and have a stylist take your particular
measurements and
a couple of weeks later you will get a
box with the best fitting suit of your
entire life
just right out of the box and if there
are any issues they will tailor it until
it fits
perfectly all for free and when i used
to buy suits off the rack i used to
spend hundreds just
on the tailoring alone but with
indochino they will make you a fully
custom tailored suit
specifically for you for less than 3.99
and the best part is
they still use the best materials like
super 140s wool i personally will never
get another off the rack suit again and
once you try indochino neither will you
and legal eagles will get a special 30
off of any purchase of 3.99 or more when
you click on the link below and enter
the code legal eagle at checkout
i cannot overstate how great having a
custom suit is and
getting a custom suit for these prices
is a complete no-brainer so just click
on the link below and use the code legal
eagle at checkout plus
clicking on that link really helps out
this channel and by the way if you do
get an industrino suit
tag me in a photo on twitter i love
seeing how fly all of you legal eagles
look
so do you agree with my analysis leave
your objections in the comments and
check out this playlist over here with
all of my other real law reviews
where i talk about home alone suits my
cousin vinnie you name it it's all right
here so click on this playlist
and i'll see you in court